there's never going to be a good time
for a massive polar blast to make its
way across North America but the timing
of this once in a generation storm could
frankly not be worse right as millions
of people are getting ready to travel
for the holidays the icy storm is
disrupting Transportation causing power
outages and putting huge pressure on
homeless shelters over half of the
United States is estimated to be under a
weather warning with a huge storm
stretching from coast to coast
bitter blizzards and severe snow do not
bode well for cross-country Christmas
travel and as America endures a once in
a generation storm some are struggling
to find the festive spirit
we don't know what's going to happen
whether or not they have extra flights
for tonight or they're saying maybe they
won't even have flights tomorrow so it's
Christmas it sucks
the weather outside truly is frightful
and it's creating travel chaos for the
millions of people headed home for the
holidays more than 3 000 flights have
been canceled many are stranded at
airports during what is one of the
busiest travel times of the year trade
like dozens and dozens of different
airports I called the the airline and
they tried but there's like no
availability until after Christmas
the severe cold isn't only a problem for
air travel driving is extremely
treacherous with roads blanketed in snow
and ice
the weather has left more than one
million homes without power
but conditions are especially dire for
those who don't have any shelter
with the cold one of the things that can
be dangerous is people can be laying on
the sidewalk or sleeping outside and you
don't always realize just how
dire of a situation that you're in it
can be really easy for people to kind of
um doze off and fall asleep and
unfortunately end up losing their lives
because of the cold weather
more than 200 million Americans are
under extreme weather advisories the
National Weather Service says it's one
of the largest warnings ever
these satellite images revealing what
Santa could be up against in time for
the big day
forecasters are warning that parts of
the country could be on track for their
coldest Christmas on record
for more let's bring ndw correspondent
to umizo muscata in Washington Sumi it
looks comparatively calm where you are
what's the situation in the country
right now
it's not as common the rest of the
country Nicole just to bring you some
numbers and more than 1.5 million homes
and businesses don't have any power
right now and more than 200 million
people which is about two-thirds of the
U.S population they are under some form
of severe winter warning or advisory and
here in DC the worst is yet to come
along the east coast the temperatures
are going to drop further tomorrow this
is a storm that is really stretched from
coast to coast we are seeing frigid
temperatures and conditions in Seattle
all the way down to Florida which is
actually going to see some really
unusually cold temperatures this weekend
as well this really is just a massive
storm and I'm from upstate New York I
live in Chicago these are places that
are used to really cold weather tons of
snow blizzards but what makes the storm
different is this bomb Cyclone effect
that meteorologists here have talked
about that is when atmospheric pressure
drops so quickly in a strong storm and
to give you an idea the city of Denver
saw temperatures drop
47 degrees in two hours 47 degree so
we're talking about plunges we don't
usually see and the other aspect there
is the wind so there is this incredible
wind chill wind has been whipping up
snow it's created whiteout conditions on
roads so as we heard this really is a
once in a generation storm
in the report we heard a woman concerned
about the fate of um of homeless people
how are people coping with this as you
say once in a generation storm
yeah this really is the biggest concern
for many people the elderly and the
homeless so those who don't have shelter
authorities in a lot of cities have been
scrambling they've opened up warming
centers and short-term Emergency
Shelters to help residents stay out of
the cold particularly the homeless and I
should say Nicole that I was just in El
Paso On the Border in Texas where
thousands of migrants have been entering
there and Texas is seeing unusually cold
temperatures we were there earlier this
week and people were sleeping on the
streets they were wrapping up in
blankets but it's getting too cold to do
even that so the city has set up some
buses where people can go inside and
warm up and they've also opened up the
convention center so people don't have
to sleep on the streets anymore but the
other big concern of course is travel we
heard in the report it is just before
Christmas you usually have millions of
people on the road or in the air heading
to their loved ones and as of now today
only more than 9 000 flights have been
canceled and even though people have
been told to stay home and stay put some
people are also taking to the roads
we've seen reports of crashes and people
getting stuck on highways
previous storms have had devastating
effects on on the infrastructure with
millions of of people left for for days
on end without power our authorities
better prepared this time around
well authorities in many cities say they
are better prepared we know that Texas
in 2021 have that massive storm that hit
the power grid really hard and
authorities there say they are better
prepared to make sure that electricity
is still available through the storm
here in Washington President Biden
addressed the storm and said he he wants
everyone to stay home and that the White
House has contacted 26 Governors to off
a offer Aid and all sorts of supplies
and help and governors across the
country have called up the National
Guard to help deal with accidents on the
road to get supplies to people who need
help they have Crews working around the
clock to ensure that roads can be
somewhat cleared especially for
emergency vehicles to pass so
authorities seem to have been preparing
all week and getting ready for this but
again Nicole these are temperatures and
this is a type of storm that is just
unprecedented
in Washington thank you so much for that
update
now over to Brian Khan who's a science
writer he covers climate change and how
Society is responding to it Mr Khan
welcome to DW this is being called a
once in a generation storm is this an
anomaly or part of a larger pattern that
we will have to get used to
I mean this storm is a little bit of
both I mean it certainly is an anomaly
in the sense that we are going to see
records fall that have been standing for
decades if not longer than that so and
in some sense this is a really unique
event that people should take seriously
whether this is part of a larger pattern
tied to climate change I think is an
area of very um you know what
researchers call Active research and so
we're still trying to tease that out but
there are some signs and ways that
climate change is influencing this type
of cold weather outbreak which may sound
a little backwards but that is a case
and something that scientists are
totally working on
uh could there be more such storms in
coming years than
I mean there could be so one of the
concerns that scientists have is that
because the Arctic is worrying faster
than the rest of the world that sort of
creates this sort of imbalance where
essentially cold air that's in the
Arctic can dip down into the
mid-latitudes like places like the US
you are places where people live with
more frequency now that is a very uh
it's something that we've seen
repeatedly over the past decade or so so
it's something that there's certainly
causal there's certainly evidence of
that whether there's a direct link is
something that people are still working
on but I think that you know it's really
important to realize that even with the
world warming we are still going to see
these cold air outbreaks and that
doesn't make them any less dangerous
how can we in our societies you know
with our infrastructure how can we adapt
to storms like these
well I think it's a question of you you
mentioned the Texas Grid in the previous
segment I mean there is there's a
reality that we saw when you don't have
infrastructure repaired when it's not
winterized that's when it goes down when
demand spikes that's when you have these
problems and so I think that you know we
have to sort of work on both sides of
the queen be prepared for the fact that
there's going to be incredible strain on
the electric grid when it's really hot
out which we'll see lots more of in the
summer so we need to start to prepare
for that while also realizing that with
these cool weather outbreaks keeping up
on winterization having redundancy
backup power making sure that people
have the resources they need maybe even
installing batteries at home those are
the kinds of things that we really need
to be thinking about so it's kind of a
two-prong approach to make sure that we
don't have bad things happen climate
editor Brian Khan thank you so much
thank you